[Music]
a safe water infrastructure is a
necessity
for a healthy community it provides
clean water to your taps
it removes waste water and it protects
the community from flooding
by managing stormwater the government
is currently reviewing how these three
water services
are delivered across the country and
along with other councils
we've committed to that first phase of
reform
in return we've received eight million
of stimulus funding which is already
helping
improve our water infrastructure in the
second stage of reform
the government is proposing that water
services will be delivered
by new regional or multi-regional
entities
and built to households separately
rather than by the council
it's not clear yet whether signing up to
this stage of the reforms
is actually going to benefit why
mccary's ratepayers
and that's because our water
infrastructure is
well maintained it's compliant and
high quality compared with other areas
until we hear from the government later
this year
we won't know exactly how this will
impact on us
but we will keep you up to date visit
waimakariri.govt.enz
forward slash let's talk to find out
more
[Music]